I would say anytime I come across either
in person or in in reading about a you
know an act of courage not even usually
or necessarily physical courage but
sometimes that but moral courage
intellectual courage I that those always
inspire me and it doesn't need to be as
dramatic as a journalist in Zimbabwe
whoo-hoo at the risk of his life and
limb or her life and limb tells the
truth but that's an example um but it
can be smaller and more banal than that
but those those those things are what
inspires me I will see a work of art I
mentioned bill viola what some of bill
violas video work I wouldn't say
inspires me but I am left awestruck and
full of of sort of a questions about
existence and perception and all kinds
of things as a result of experiencing
various works of art same as true of
fiction films all kinds of things but
and so I am often amazed and inspired by
the the skill and luck of those creators
but but in terms of how I since inspired
it is really the you know I would say
the most common way in which I feel
inspired and try to remind myself to do
the right thing is when people behave
courageously my creative process
depending it depends on what I'm doing I
mean there to the degree my life now is
is divided between working alone in a
room essentially writing fiction or
writing essays it's a matter of doing
whatever research is necessary and then
just being at home
with all of whatever facts there are
notes thoughts stray stray bits and
letting that marinate and tell I can
figure out a way that looks interesting
or enlightening or entertaining to to
write a page so I I don't have a mcwire
for me it requires to do what I consider
good writing to be alone in a room for
you know a few hours at a time and then
whatever alchemy happens happens but
then the other half of my creative life
which is doing the studio 360 s as was
doing magazines editing magazines in the
past is this entirely collaborative
process tote entirely or significantly
and vastly different from the creative
process of writing which is about
finding a team of people with whom
you're comfortable but not identical and
being open to all of the various ideas
and approaches that that team brings and
and and if you're the leader of the team
trying to to inspire those people to do
good work and and and and and and keep a
vision of what it is you're trying to do
collaboratively so it's not just a
collection of ten people doing ten
different things but all fits into the
to the larger the larger vision and so
though as I say those are those are very
different i get satisfaction out of both
and and and very happy that i literally
my days are divided between those two
forms of creative process so you know by
the time i'm done doing a radio program
in all the meetings and conversations
and back and forth that requires i'm
very happy the next morning to go back
in my room and spend five hours alone
I have never suffered from writer's
block I I when I'm working on a book I'm
pretty disciplined unless I have
something else I have to do about going
in the room and and and working some
days the result is crap and I throw that
away so you know I can imagine having
writer's block because I can imagine I
don't know if this is how it is for
other writers but feeling as though
you're writing the crap as you're
writing it and then stopping because you
can't bear to commit crap to the page
anymore but so I never have had it and I
even though I you know listen to the
critic within mere the editor within me
as I'm writing I think that's
unavoidable I can turn it off or turn it
down enough that I am able to write
through the kind of distant criticism in
the back of my head